you are saying ecology will not accept
Israeli government to keep practicing it
it services policies in
the Cirelli government is being as
racist as they can in the Negev and
trying to take all the land from them
we're here to say that we're willing to
do anything to get our recognization
from the society government and to be
that body that will never shut up from
his rights
these red states will tear down villages
will try to move these people around
claiming that they are big ones and big
ones are used to moving around and they
never settle down in one place
we have to remember that those that the
people who are living in the
undergraduate are Israeli citizens like
others like those people who are living
those buildings around us
you